and beliefs about god
without having to go through any
transformation so theology gets divorced
from self-transcendence around the year
1200 yeah that's when it starts
happening why
because the reading is changing oh okay
okay and the reading changed because
probably for reasons you said i mean
there's many ways in which i can
i can make my reading much more
efficient much more effective
i can consume more information right if
i
if i read in this silent fashion but now
i start to think of myself inside my
head
and that i am my beliefs and that
meaning is in the propositions in my
head
rather than the meaning that was carried
in
my in this reciprocal realization
between me and the text
and this mutual transformation right
okay so now there's a separation that's
right
and then and and and and at the same
time
aristotle's being rediscovered right
and so aristotle is like to the ancient
world
he's science he literally writes all the
books on science like literally
right and so when aristotle's being
rediscovered
you know you've got all this scientific
knowledge that's coming in and it can't
be ignored by the christian church right
it can't be ignored because of the
authority they give to
the ancient world and also because you
know aristotle and plato
you know had deep influences on people
like augustine and
so they can't just ignore aristotle but
they can't simply assimilate
so they've already respected aristotle
or there's great respect for aristotle
that has been set up within sort of
some it's in the warp and the woof of of
of you know
the way in which christianity had
integrated with the platonic tradition
around what year was oh so the plateau
the integration with the platonic
tradition starts much much earlier
oh well no that's much later i mean i'm
i'm actually getting to aquinas in this
picture that we're talking about
but no this is much earlier you're
seeing this in the you know in the third
and fourth century
and and most especially in the fifth
century with augustine
augustine is the person that really
fuses christianity
and platonism together but you're also
seeing it in uh
in eastern christianity you're seeing it
with pseudo-diagnosis and when you say
he's fusing it it's not as if he's
taking passages from aristotle and
putting it in the bible no no what you
mean is
he's respecting their line of thinking
and then applying it to the bible yes so
uh uh in fact augustine famously argued
that he could not have become a
christian
until he was exposed to platonism
because
plato's way of thinking about
like the upper world right the platonic
way of thinking like the idealized world
yeah yeah that that gave august
because augustine was a very much sort
of a materialist in his way of thinking
and he he couldn't get into christianity
because he didn't know how to
relate to this god that was this
invisible unseeable
he was an atheist before well no he's a
manichaeanist
he follows he follows the religion of
manny which was a very sort of dualistic
very materialistic uh especially his
version of it
um and sorry i keep interrupting no no
no no no no no do what you want
so he right he can't
get to this incorporeal invisible god
until
he reads plato and plato gives him the
conceptual grammar
so that he's then capable of moving into
christianity you can see that i find it
hard to relate to this because
for me hearing this and for most people
i would imagine were so
ingrained i mean our thinking is so
ingrained and rooted and fortified
in a rational aristotelian platonic way
of thinking
that to think that people didn't think
that way
is difficult so how did you come about
how do you even
imagine it because to me i can only sort
of understand it on an intellectual
level
but not i can't put myself in that
perspective
so i'm not clear which perspective
you're referring to the perspective of
people that are sort of non-platonic
so in one of your lectures you were
talking about how
rational knowledge i mean rational lines
of thinking logic
is pretty new it came about with the
greeks people didn't think
logically yeah yeah rationally they have
to teach that
and now we it's so taken for granted
that when you don't you say i'm being
irrational and you don't like it
yeah yeah that's right and it's
difficult to think of it's
difficult to not think rationally well
it is um again but if only if you're
using introspection
as your way of evaluating and
interpreting and examining your own
experience